shannon is i mean she's one tough cookie  iins earring praises his former Beverly  Hills 90210 co-star shannen doherty as  she bravely fights breast cancer et was  exclusively with the sharknado star on  Thursday at his home in LA where he  offered his support for the 45 year old  actress had you had any idea that she'd  been battling cancer for the last year  well we heard some news of that several  months ago and then of course when she  shaved her head and put the pictures on  Twitter and demonstrated a tremendous  amount of bravery I gave her a call last  week and just let her know that I was  thinking about her and Shannon is I mean  she's one tough cookie if she could have  had if she could handle the the press  outlets that were roasting her backbend  and I'm sure cancers really you know she  could stand up that if anybody can  you